kenny tu peut trancher la poitrine ce
sera fait comme ça à 25 ans seulement
catherine et responsable des ventes et
dirige déjà sa propre équipe pour une
grande enseigne de viande la boucherie
c'est 10 % de femmes pour 90 % d'hommes
un milieu dans lequel catherine a su
s'imposer malgré tout à la base ça reste
un métier d'homme mais on voit quand
même de plus en plus de ça de bouchehr
qui accède à cette profession c'est vrai
que c'est difficile c'est assez rude
on travaille dans le froid les horaires
sont assez il faut se lever tôt le matin
c'est à 3 heures du matin faut être sûr
dans le bio j'ai un mental de rock
d'acier donc c'est ce qui m'a apporté
beaucoup de choses aussi pour le
management d'une équipe d'hommes en fait
et avec ceci madame vous avez la promo
du rosbif aujourd'hui un tempérament
récompensés puisque catherine est
aujourd'hui représentante de la marque
au salon de l'agriculture
nous l'avons rencontrée en séance de
démonstration je m'apprête à faire un
filet mignon on cherche donc tout ça
donc la base un filet mignon et petites
tomates cerises pour la décoration
l'ag de la crépine pour l'entourer
persil et le fromage une représentation
d'une journée où catherine mettra en
valeur avec fierté sa profession en
préparant des pièces de viande sous les
yeux des visiteurs
très impressionnant faut vraiment être
réveillé faut être sur le qui vive
il ya beaucoup de gens qui posent des
questions qui demandent ce qu'on fait ça
représente tout notre travail ça
représente la france en général c'est en
valorisant ce métier à travers justement
une personnalité féminine qu'on va
justement développer ce métier on
diminue le côté boucher avec le ventre
rond la moustache et on passe sur un
métier vraiment dynamique avec des
jeunes femmes qui trouve vraiment leur
voix dans le métier évolution et la mise
en avant de la femme dans un milieu où
elle est peu représentée est une des
valeurs de cette enseigne boucherie un
secteur qui ne connaît pas la crise
dans les deux prochaines années ce sont
4500 postes qui sont à pourvoir dans le
secteur